the negotiations over enhanced
unemployment benefits comes on the heels
of the july jobs report
the labor department says 1.8 million
new jobs were created last month
that knocked down the nation's
unemployment rate to 10.2 percent
but the pace of hiring appears to be
slowing as more states hit the brakes
on their plans to reopen for more we're
joined by cbs news senior business
analyst jill schlesinger jill good
morning to you let's
get right into this we know that we've
seen a surge in south and west
states when it comes to this coronavirus
but we also see that some states are
starting to slowly
recover what does the picture look like
for states overall when we're talking
about recovery
well i think that the economy really did
bottom out at the end of march beginning
of april
overall and we saw that with the jobs
situation
we lost 22 million jobs in march and
april
then the next two months when we look at
may and june
we regained seven and a half million
jobs which is a huge number
now we get the most recent data for july
1.8 million jobs so what does that tell
us it tells us that
the pace of growth is slowing down some
but it's still growth and that is good
news i think economists are quite
concerned about what happens going
forward
especially as things have slowed down
and we see a surge of virus
in the south in the west and now even in
the midwest
i think that there are hopes that things
get better
but the reality on the ground is things
are
really tough we have 12.9 million
fewer jobs than we had just in february
joel the great the great recession
lasted for 18 months right december 2007
uh to june of 2009 it was dramatically
different time weren't dealing with a
pandemic then any indication now
how long this recession takes well
you know when you look at the job growth
and you look
at the economic path it looks like the
u.s
economy will not get back to where we
were prior to the pandemic
until you're ready for this the end of
2021
so we are talking like a long time
now the idea here though is that if we
can control the path of the virus the
economy may do better
jerome powell the federal reserve
chairman has basically said hey
look at the path of the virus that will
tell you where the economy is going next
jill a lot of workers right now are
caught in this vicious cycle of being
laid off and then rehired and laid off
and then rehired the end of the paycheck
protection program
it seems like that means a final layoff
is coming for some of them it may be
good for businesses but it's not good
for workers
so how do you fix that well there has to
be some fix
if you want to do if you want to help
the small business universe
we have a survey out from cornell
university
which found some staggering numbers
found that
31 of those surveyed were actually
rehired by the payroll protection
program
then were laid off again and then we'd
say
another 26 percent say they too think
they will be laid off in the future
it is grim for small business they
probably need help more than
anyone any other type of business as
well as their
employees who need that six hundred
dollars a week
okay jules lessinger as always thank you
very much